my name is Brent beer I'm one of the
trainer's here at github which usually
entails sometimes doing online classes
classes in-person or sometimes with
enterprise customers doing private
courses as well so one of the things
that confuses people often when they
first start is well I know I've heard
about git and I've heard about github
you know what is the difference between
the two and get itself being the version
control tool that github is built on so
git is largely the thing that will be
interacting with on the laptop doing
that local work first and soon as we use
a few choice commands and send things up
to github that's when it's more of the
social component or it didn't that its
networked it's in the cloud if you
wanted to use that term as well so git
as local github is where we share and
collaborate with other people the reason
why I like pull requests is because it
allows us to really get that work that
we're wanting to kind of work on and
complete that feature and allow us to
collaborate with other people just to
show them our work get feedback on it so
that we can have people kind of working
with us as they choose to or as we want
to pull other people into the work
itself
when github started you know a few years
ago kind of as out of a need for the
Ruby community to have ways to kind of
share their code and collaborate it's
expanded past that and now you know a
lot more open source communities and
languages have you know grown within
github in the github ecosystem so github
has helped the open-source community and
helped make it a little bit better by
allowing us to have this centralized
place where we can talk about any
features that we're wanting to work on
any problems that we might have as we
decide to share code around or
incorporate code into other projects so
it helps the communities kind of have a
place where they can pull together talk
about their new features and work
through problems together
in fact the node community itself is one
of the larger communities that first
started out after github was already
around so they were able to flourish as
a community whereas other communities
maybe were older and came to get hub
later and then grew from there